bonsoir dans cette émission nous allons
vous donner des idées de recettes pour
des repas de fête des idées pour des
estomacs sensibles les idées pour des
petites bourses et puis des idées
originales des idées de fait en sommes
rendus dans différents lieux nous avons
rencontré différentes personnes tout
d'abord au lycée hôtelier de bonneveine
à marseille un professeur de cuisine
nous donnera entre autres un menu
diététique dans un restaurant du vieux
port de chef à chef cuisinier un chef
pâtissier nous ont livré deux de leurs
secrets pour une entrée et pour un
dessert et puis un confrère de la
rédaction de fr3 marsa et la fois un
gourmand et gourmet vous avez peut-être
reconnu et gérard paolini il fera sous
nos yeux une de ses recettes originales
à la fois agréable à l'oeil
agréable au palais facile à réaliser et
surtout pas cher il s'agite des pieds
paquets de la mer voilà donc tout de
suite quelques idées pour ceux et celles
qui n'ont pas encore tout à fait décider
de ce qu'ils allaient mettre sur la
table le soir de noël